a CBS News poll out this morning shows
most Americans believe President Trump
was right to attack a Syrian Air Base
but they do not want any larger military
action 57% in our poll approve of last
week's missile strike in response to a
poison gas attack on civilians 36
percent disapproved but only 18 percent
would accept American ground troops in
Syria another 30 percent would go along
with future strikes and 26 percent want
to see peace talks in Syria without
military action Russia and Iran the two
main allies of Syria's president told
the u.s. they will respond with force to
any further attacks on Syria the airbase
that was hit by dozens of US cruise
missiles is now back in service major
garrett is at the White House with the
split inside the Trump administration
over the next move in Syria major good
morning good morning the airstrikes gave
President Trump a small boost in his
approval rating three points it's now up
to 43%
but our survey also showed Democrats and
independents wonder if the president can
handle the suit the Civil War inside
Syria what comes next is the question
most on their minds and it's a big
question
inside this White House as well this is
a president that's not afraid to act
Trump administration officials called
the president decisive but were divided
on the future of US policy in Syria
after last week's cruise missile strikes
on the airbase that launched a sarin gas
attack on civilians what we're trying to
do is obviously defeat Isis United
Nations ambassador nikki Haley and
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson agreed
the fate of Isis was more important than
that of Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad
the first priority is the defeat of Isis
but on Assad's future the two top Trump
diplomats differed Tillerson suggested
Assad's future was in the hands of a
country beleaguered by six years of
civil war that we can navigate a
political outcome in which the Syrian
people in fact will determine Bashar
al-assad's fate while Haley called for
Assad a ouster there's not any sort of
option where a political solution is
gonna happen with Assad at the head of
the regime this led South Carolina's
Republican Lindsey Graham to describe a
new Trump approach regime changes now
the policy the trumpet Minister
that's at least what I heard what's
required is some kind of a political
solution to that very complex problem
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
said serious civil war with its many
factions and feuding terrorist cells
rests at the heart of the policy dilemma
dislodging Assad some Administration
officials fear could be just as bad or
worse than the status quo it's very
difficult to understand how a political
solution could result from the
continuation of the Assad regime now
what we're not saying that we are the
ones who are going to affect that change
an equally pressing issue how to handle
Syria's top military ally Russia I hope
that Russia is thinking carefully about
its continued - lives with Bashar
al-assad because every time one of these
horrific attacks occurs it draws Russia
or closer into some level of
responsibility Tillerson is traveling to
Moscow and will soon meet with Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov to find out if
the Vladimir Putin government is willing
or interested in backing away from the
Assad regime at any level the White
House is also dealing with a staff
sheikha katie mcfarland is out as the
deputy national security adviser she was
brought in as part of the leadership
team under fired National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn Charlie McFarlane
will soon be nominated as the next US
ambassador to Singapore thanks major